hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is google pixel book love the name uh
this thing was announced alongside the
pixel 2 and it's in google's holiday
season product lineup alongside the home
mini and other things like that
and this thing
is really weird to me now i love the
chromebook pixel which was the last
high-end chromebook that google made but
i was very careful to only recommend it
to certain smaller groups of people who
knew what they were getting themselves
into
this pixel book while it is an amazing
piece of hardware is even harder to
recommend to an even smaller group of
people
because of all its weirdness so
pixelbook is a high-end laptop with a
touchscreen that folds over into tablet
mode
and runs chrome os and it starts at a
thousand bucks so okay aesthetically it
is pretty nice it takes after the pixel
smartphones with the glass window up top
and this all metal very angular boxy
design it's super thin i don't even
think i've ever held a laptop this thin
before and this thing feels like more
like a thick tablet instead of a thin
laptop it's crazy sharp so i'm honestly
a big fan of the aesthetics on the
outside the soft palm rest surrounding
the touch pad is really cool
minimal fingerprints are going to show
with this design with this silver and
white color combo and even the hinge is
pretty sturdy and minimal
the thing is flanked by two usb c ports
one on either side and of course both
can be used for charging and there's a
headphone jack and that's it i guess
that's all the i o most laptops seem to
need these days so that doesn't strike
me as weird at the core and inside
you're looking at a seventh generation
intel core i5 eight gigs of ram 128 gigs
of storage really beefy specs at the
baseline version and you can bump it up
to an i7 and 16 gigs of ram and a half
terabyte nvme ssd if you want which is
nuts and then all up at the front is the
12 inch 4x3 display it's a crispy bright
2400 by 1600 touch screen display the
whole thing is fanless you know all
solid state no moving parts basically
this hardware actually has a lot going
on that wouldn't make you blink twice at
that thousand dollar price tag but
here's the thing and you probably saw
this coming at a thousand bucks you know
you can say okay this is a really nice
hardware i can see that but this thing
is running chrome os
you know what else you can get for a
thousand bucks
the highest end biggest newest ipad pro
you know what else you can get for a
thousand bucks the microsoft surface
laptop a macbook air so this thing is
kind of competing with those in that
price point and then my philosophy on
two and ones has always kind of been
when you're trying to be both a laptop
and a tablet you inevitably get a little
bit worse at being a laptop than
dedicated laptops and a little bit worse
at being a tablet than dedicated tablets
so this is a decent laptop and a decent
tablet but it's not fantastic at either
but even more awkward about the pixel
book is just all the weird quirks it has
that add up these bezels around the
display definitely huge like bigger than
i think they'd need to be i understand
you know you need some place to put your
hands when you're holding a thing in
tablet mode but damn that is just weird
the speakers are just kind of behind the
keyboard
and they don't sound that great now i
get that it's thin and it's probably the
only place they could fit these speakers
but couldn't they put a grill about the
top it's weird flipping it around into
tablet mode and having the keyboard
behind the display like this no matter
how long i use it it feels weird every
time i'm constantly pressing keys on the
back i know other two and one laptops do
this too and it turns off the keyboard
so they're not actually typing anything
but still holding something like this
and trying to ignore all the buttons on
the back as easy as they are to press
is just kind of weird and i've said for
years i've always found using touch
screen laptops a little bit awkward
because of the hinge wobble this one is
no exception to that rule and the screen
jittering even though the performance is
fast when i scroll through menus or long
lists or long pages on the pixel book
there's some serious ghosting and
stuttering of animations that i did not
expect to see on a chromebook with a
core i5 and then there is the pixelbook
pen this thing is a 100 accessory first
of all so there's that a long metal tube
with a battery inside one button and the
stylus tip 100 bucks uh it doesn't come
with any replacement tips like even the
ipad's pencil or surface stylus do and
most others do weird this thing uses
quadruple a batteries
what
have you ever heard of these luckily
they're supposed to last about a year
each but
wow okay that is also pretty weird and
you'd think they would have thought of
this but there's really just no place to
keep it when you're not using it there's
no magnet no clip if you don't have that
it's just kind of rolling around loose
and you have to press it obnoxiously
hard to actually use it has anyone
actually tried to use this stylus i have
a hard time finding other people's
reviews talking about this but maybe
mine has some sort of problem because it
doesn't work at all with normal pressure
that i might use with apple's pencil for
example
the only way i can get it to work
reliably is by pressing so hard that i'm
literally bending the display a little
like you can see it here and at that
point it obviously doesn't feel natural
anymore super weird and then there is
chrome os so you guys already know
chrome pretty well obviously it's been
limited for a while by not having all of
the professional apps someone buying a
thousand dollar laptop might use but to
be fair this is all most people really
need it's all your web apps and all of
your android apps from the play store
but there's no doubt you can do more
with a full-fledged desktop os like on a
mac or a windows laptop most of the
adobe suite is missing
certain apps you won't find if you're a
student even on the ipad the app store
is much more massive and more
importantly more optimized and then
another weird thing is now that you have
the play store and the chrome store a
lot of times on this pixel book you have
two options for the same service the web
app in chrome or the android app so
youtube for example there's two icons in
my launcher a web app for youtube.com or
the android youtube app and they do a
good job of distinguishing between them
so you never really get them confused
but it's just kind of weird to sometimes
open the youtube app in desktop mode
when i'm using it as a laptop but then
other times open it as a tablet mode
when i want to kick back but look among
all this weirdness don't get me wrong
chrome os definitely has its advantages
like some really cool features on this
guy pixelbook automatically tethers to
your google pixel if you have one for
mobile data when you don't have wi-fi
that's pretty cool
it has a couple custom buttons on the
keyboard that you probably won't find
anywhere else my favorite probably being
the assistant button to call google
assistant anytime you want clearly you
can see how hard google is pushing it it
has a power button and a volume button
on the side kind of like a normal tablet
so you can hold down the power button
for a second to lock it when you're
going away and if you pair it to your
phone you can unlock pixelbook with your
phone's fingerprint sensor that is
seriously cool and the stylus has of
course that one button where if you hold
it while circling an image it'll do a
google search for that image to find
what it is or where it came from but are
those two things enough to justify you
spending your thousand bucks on this
over a surface laptop or over an ipad
pro or over a macbook air
i don't really think so and so it's
really really hard for me to recommend
pixelbook like i said when you make a
two in one like this you inevitably get
a little bit worse at being a laptop and
a little bit worse at being a tablet so
it's just kind of okay at both
again
so that's pretty much it thank you for
watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you